Film Courage: Your first draft…how much
weight do you let it carry and then how much
time (you talk about giving time/space to
actually reading the story), doing other things,
trying to forget about it, then coming back
to it.
What about the first draft?
Phyllis Nagy, Screenwriter of CAROL Movie:
In what do you mean, do I let it sit for awhile?
Film Courage: How much weight do you actually
give it or obsess over it…you know they
call it the vomit draft…
Phyllis Nagy: Yeah, I’m not a vomiter.
And mostly I think that when scripts are not
right fundamentally in their first drafts,
they never will be, hence four, five, six
writers being called on to something in service
that wasn’t right to begin with.
So you should get a new take rather than try
to put a bandaid on something that doesn’t
work.
I wish more weight and more time were given
to first drafts because they are often the
draft that’s closest to something electric
whether you’re writing a thriller or a quiet
little movie or a comedy and subsequent drafts
and however long someone works on something
in the end and it always ends up going back
to an earlier state when you’ve got the
right people working on something.
It’s always (in my experience) goes back
to its first fundamental state with improvements.